I can say that it's you know it's bigger
it's darker it's scarier I think they
really brought it to a new level this
year there are things that you associate
with the summer there's different
activities that do you think about
things that go along with summer and
you're outside different kind of
activities and place that you find
yourself and clothes are very different
which is so fun summer ladies clothes
are great yeah it's just a different
vibe in general it's a different vibe
breath filming honestly so I'm curious
as well to see how look like the overall
tone of the show
Natalia Dyer giving et a little stranger
things tease to hold us over until July
4th when the show returns for season 3
the 22 year old actress and her
boyfriend is / stranger things co-star
Charlie Heaton stepped out in style for
the premiere of her new movie velvet
buzz-saw the thriller comes to Netflix
February 1st and co-stars Jake
Gyllenhaal it's such a learning
experience he's very
intense but at the same time very
personable yeah really listen to
everything he was saying to me
constantly it was such a collaboration
the whole stat just felt very you know
open a trying name so misery knows he
was great
[Music]
[Applause]